hey guys I'm Ryan right I am Joe beak
away we're gonna check out today from
all-time movies top 10 deadliest movie
assassins here we go we know a thing or
two about action heroes and assassins
and all that so let's see what they
choose hey guys I'm Chris and here is my
list of the top 10 deadliest assassins
now for the record I'm talking about
actual contract killers whose profession
is killing discreet it's as much about
the style and success of the killing as
it is how many people they actually kill
yes so modern forces do not count but
before we begin an honorable mention
goes to crazy Miguel Bane from
Assassin's yeah there's a lot of people
but he's not subtle about it and doesn't
really bother about sticking to his
actual contract market remember though
big honor it is between number 10
where's the Gibson wanted nicely
on-screen I would say is one of the
Delian Chris Pratt manna for not about
that long long long way away even if you
think his superpower is stupid I do deny
that as long as he's got a garden he
will hit you with it although you
wouldn't be anywhere without Fox
by the time at number nine Martin Blake
Grosse Pointe blank one screen kills 10
Martin blank
is stylish you see this loner Hey - good
job in other words a classic assassin
Swami
he's a reluctant killer but overcomes
other assassins and mercenaries in
pretty imaginative ways he's not quite
Jason Bourne but he does make a clean
getaway not how badass great you ii
Vincent yeah yeah let's go put him up on
a high realism Tom Cruise should play
more bad guys that's just a fact
yeah he's the most efficient killer ever
so I hit with one light and a signal
that's not my favorite movies of all
time he dispatches each victim with
brutal efficiency what's more his
reasons actually kind of make sense and
we got to make the best of it
improvise adapt to the environment
Darwin [ __ ] happens in each chain
whatever man you got a role with him his
technique enter that one really genius
he frames cab drivers for the murders he
commits and he never shows his face to
anyone I mean of course he's insane was
so smug [ __ ] being reliable and
actually kind of charming I'm very happy
to meet you mister he is so getting that
many eggs it's like a Tom Cruise but
it's over seven Jason Bourne the board
song I come on screen kills over 11 ish
okay okay so we only meet him oh he said
he stopped being we Jason Bourne and Tom
Cruise but it's obvious that he's a
super assess I know but he can talk to
the other assassin and he can she goes
down with me anything literally I don't
like that book like I thought that ice
Dom your right away no gloves can hurt
that's good however by the third film he
kills hardly anyone because well hey
he's given up on his killing career he
only kills people who attack him Clive
Owens - let's take a walk but he does
manage to get away in da honorable
mention Evelyn Salt
she's no saint God it's an honorable
mention why he sounds like if this is on
the list I don't know man number 6
yeah okay I'll get there my one screen
kills when you hold still think she was
so creepy about seven maybe more no
Anton is the most terrifying assassin on
this list at Sallee remorseless and
relentless he's basically and spanic
terminator ah he only kills people he
needs to and might even let you live if
he thinks you're not a threat
oh you know if you win the coin toss
well done and to top it all off he lives
to kill another day another honorable
mention ghost dog who has ever so little
or no vision mm-hmm but no in here is to
remember the trailers number five a
personal favorite at all side movies
Ivan Ivanov is midnight now on screen
kills 58 Charli Baltimore is another
member of an easy answer conspiracy
theory moving on abyss but she has the
edge on I remember by being a nineties
action I very very confusing something
about Doug Dickey no she snaps shoots
and explodes away Wow an army of CIA
solokha I need two one
and she fights she gets to a normal life
I'm lucky she is the most kick this is
like a former assassin or something
number four yeah uh you're the killer
you got this on screen kills seventeen
one
oh yeah who's got your sire so many he
drinking he kills him as much it's
ridiculous
you haven't seen this higher of it it's
like even heart sound crazy how many
people are in this movie and if you
could do more like almost every single
minute someone's getting shot number
three mr. and mrs. Smith I don't know
mr. and mrs. Smith don't Google
no that's a good movie but I don't agree
with this come on that's when Brad Pitt
started cheating on Jennifer Aniston's
what problems you saying you could put
this above the killer this is just no
way it team up against your employers
but they're going to kill you they win
in the end music doesn't really matter
because these guys are hot
I mean sure they have an advantage by
working together but that just makes
them even more deadly Angelina Jolie has
quite the repertoire of deadly assassins
but mrs. Smith is by far the best one
number two yeah one semester that you
know on-screen killed 50 alone is bad
eyes with Z nominated his daughters are
monsters yeah it doesn't kill chemistry
he does exactly what he's hired to do he
does however have a vulnerable tendency
to take care of the innocent plant but
it takes an entire SWAT army to get to
it and even then he actually comes out
on top because he's always got a bath
yeah
honorable mention goes to the Jekyll
he's a slick and for that movie yeah we
check wax arm gets blown off she fails
weapon and finally okay are but bright
that's one of my favorite movie for
screen kills seventy yeah right is a
monster yeah I was happy to be on this
list I mean she can even wiggle her
tongue amazing
yeah yeah I mean not even death will
stop this chick she beats every one of
the deadly Viper assassination squad and
the crazy 88 and that's all after she's
been shot in the head and put in a coma
I'm gonna realize what is going on it
likely she gets shot and then wakes up
like like are you buck and then like bad
die ready
I'm Pete cheese just a measure which was
like when she was less emotional
Wow wow what a list what an interesting
list they got you let's let's go through
some of these cats that they put it out
here I don't agree with some of them
though I mean I know they're not
finalized list Lesley Gibson and wanted
I really like wanted I mean I could see
how we'd be number ten on the list or at
least an honorable mention I don't know
I kind of like the powers and [ __ ] that
he has with a little curving the bullet
and it's it feels like it doesn't belong
to because of the other all the other
films feel like they've got some basis
in reality except for mr. and mrs. Smith
like they feel like they're trying to be
real words this feels like it's trying
to be a superhero movie well it is a
graphic novel based movie okay mr. mrs.
Smith kind of falls under the realm of a
little bit more realism though
especially more than wanted
I don't know that whole dancing gun
sequence at the end that was pretty
awesome I thought they were it was I it
was yeah right he's like honor playing
some sad music right now that was kind
of a random I like that that was that
was that was a cool like contrasting
song for the situation I think when the
professional definitely belongs up there
I think Tom Cruise's character Vincent
from collateral Vinson from collateral
definitely belongs up there how great is
you know I have been defending Tom
Cruise the way I've been defending Mel
Gibson through this crisis lately it
wasn't so Ghost Protocol where he
started getting some respect back again
and before that I was really defending
this guy and just watching two clips of
him collateral like that's the movie
where he's playing an antagonist he was
a superstar already at that time right
and he was totally believable as his bad
guy right you know that's it's harder to
buy someone as in such a villainous role
when they have such a charming celebrity
status but he managed it he managed to
take that celebrity charm that he
naturally possesses and turn it into the
cent agonist so you're not missing out
on the Tom Cruise that you also love
you're like oh he's Will Smith and after
earth like werster's charisma
right now he's really cool you know what
he did to prepare for that role he had
Tom Cruise delivering FedEx packages he
had to go in without being recognized
and deliver and leave all right yeah
like he was actually meeting people they
had no idea who he was
he had to do gun training and whatnot
like all that precise gun stuff you've
seen the film yeah he actually trained
in that oh cool yeah I remember that
first time like he pulls out a gun and
kills people when Jamie Foxx's
handcuffed to the car you know actually
here I thought was handcuffed to the UM
whatever Oh steering wheel whatever it
is he's handcuffed right and he goes to
get his suitcase back and he takes up
those two guys like bam bam it's like
screw shots to the chest and one to the
head it was so quick I'd never seen
anything like that before he whips out
that gun really fast
yeow-kee imagine him in bed faster whip
that thing out you be if you be
orgasming before you even you Jason
Bourne I he was an obvious one that
would be on this list
you seem like you disagreed though I
didn't think of him when I thought of
this list because I'm thinking of people
who are borderline bad guy yeah like
some kind of villainous like oh when
murderers people in [ __ ] like Leon the
professional kind of fits in that
category where he's kind of a bad dude
even though he does good things and he
tries to take care of like this may roll
the Hitman at the end isn't it what is
it exactly is it he's a contract killer
you don't think of Jason Bourne that way
you think of Jason Bourne as a hero as
the as the good guy who's trying to do
what's right so I didn't feel like he
should have been here even though it was
obvious to you
I like the Bourne movies I think they're
great you don't like them I'm not gonna
say anything because I'm gonna piss
people off the director because the
camera is always doing this [ __ ] and I
can't see what's happening and gets
progressively worse the first movie was
bearable the second movie was way worse
the third movie was just ridiculous
where the cameras like on people's eyes
and [ __ ] I'm like they're just talking
what are you doing it just let them talk
but it makes it more realistic and that
you're in the world more because
apparently documentarians
have the worst camera scope
yeah that's you're making a point I know
that I don't mind it though I agree with
what's-his-name from No Country for Old
Men being Javier Bardem yeah totally
totally belonging he's kind of got
typecast as villains ever since then
granted I've only seen him play one
other villain so I don't know if he's
been typecast no he played a lover who
got two women into bed at the same time
in a Woody Allen movie that is kind of
villainous because of you know that
motion aliy confusing for that [ __ ] was
so slick I'm like to try that out one
day when I am when I'm actually single
I've tried everything from movies and do
my Thurman in Kill Bill it was weird I
wasn't expecting her to be number one me
neither I wanted her on this list now
but I can tell because the Kill Bill Vol
1 is I always consider in my top 5
favorite films we were different ages at
the time when when I saw it and when you
saw it for me I remember that was two
very different theatre experiences you
went in like the morning with friends to
go watch you know I went at the opening
night with a crowd and I was by myself
because dad either said somewhere else I
had never seen a Tarantino film at that
time really yeah this is a first
Tarantino film I ever saw Wow
and it was like magical for me to watch
this movie what an introduction so to
have such a film like of like kung-fu
love and all this like and being young
like I wasn't even a teenager yet but
you seen all that violence was like
surprisingly entertaining and stuff what
this ducks list doesn't take into
account is how many people are killed
off screen how many people were killed
before the characters come into the
movie yeah it's only looking at what you
actually see and that kind of that kind
of bothers me just a little bit cuz I'm
like child fed killed way more people
than mineral or evenly on the
professional like you know that what
they show you in the movie is just like
just a sliver of what he's done over the
course of his career but this list could
have done a little better is really look
at the character and see how far this
character is willing to go like I could
see Huma Thurman's on the top five
because this woman's willing to kill
like no matter what and she'll [ __ ]
hack you up into pieces and she has to
you know Jason Bourne will like I
wouldn't call him one of the deadliest
less you a couple punch you a couple
times of you with a book or something
and then he might you
out or something but he's not gonna like
murder someone you right
they made a shout out to the jackal I
think Bruce fools in the movies really
really really scary yeah cuz he just
will he'll Oh would he call it he makes
out with a guy I know he'll to anything
and then he shot the dude he was really
scary in that movie that's a violent
movie I wish mom and dad didn't show me
certain movies before I was the
thirteenth that's what I think would
make them more deadly beyond their
skills it's about how far they willing
to go you know like you could even say
that man had years of training but he
doesn't kill anyone right but he
technically could probably kill Jason
Bourne or something the same time he's
not willing to go that far so I think
the assassin level is more about what is
there I don't know the word for it
tolerance is something you know well
just what they're willing to go you said
it yeah
I've said it like 19 times mm anyway
guys thanks for tuning in to the channel
if you're new to it you can subscribe to
the real rejects you can check out the
Jabby Kawai channel just type in YouTube
page comm YouTube page calm and you'll
seriously get he got the domain or on
Twitter and vine and Instagram at jeddak
away mm-hmm and I have a facebook
Instagram Twitter vine and periscope I
needed I need a domain we should do
periscope more often does it have to be
YouTube page or can it be like like
fresh vegetables calm what I think we
have a fan bases really like vegetable
drawn or like minor mediators or medium
sized penises calm I tried to get um
[ __ ] calm I couldn't get it oh yeah
I got that already Jax